attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
non c'est un pas les nouvelles cabines
un nouveau mec
ouais je t'ai rencontrée sur facebook il
va de charybde dans la pub comme ça mais
qui stoppe ma soeur il peut pas me
plaire en tout cas merci de me garder
cela pour ce week end ses adorables ah
oui que vous faire la fête à pelleter
potes et puis quand vous regardez chassé
pour ma gueule on met tout un bon
feeling avec les animaux je monte la
litière des conquêtes
non non c'est vrai j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
du chamois si j'ai dit oui c'est surtout
pour faire une grosse fête dans son
appartement
enfin ces locations ouais je comprends
mais de toute façon on ne serait pas là
pour vérifier ça veut dire le trampoline
iba dans la cuisine et du coup tofaïl
cardiaque
ah non il y aura pas de fête ici qu'est
ce que t'es redouté jamais fait de
grandes fêtes pour t'amuser toi mais
bien sûr que si mais toujours chez les
autres et je rangeais jamais le
lendemain je te rassure ce sera un petit
comité
par contre il y aura pas mal d'alcool
donc on n'est pas l'abri de 30 et jet
c'est lui qu'est ce que tu fous là mec
c'est génial on est beau frère diplôme à
temps mais d'où tu sors avec max martin
en fait quand j'étais ajouté sur
facebook j'ai aussi ajouté toutes les
meufs banchetta d'un ami elle fait qu'on
ait même nom de famille dont sa tape
attirer l'oeil non ce qui m'a attiré
l'oeil cc 12 parle de moi parce que je
me demandais comment ma soeur pouvait se
taper mon collègue en fait moi je vais
expliquer qu'il avait espionné sur
facebook et quand on ment sur l'album
corse 2016 j'avais craqué je sais c'est
ma qu'ils aient choisi les photos c'est
le quatrième du choc comme ça assez le
dossier où tu fais un peu put way est
belle
[Musique]